the war between the intelligence
community and the incoming president
Donald Trump is escalating just days
before his inauguration the entire
Russia dossier is fake news claim has
been utterly demolished last week
Director of National Intelligence James
clapper rejected out of hand from
suggestion that the intelligence
community was responsible for leaking
that dossier to the media and now
outgoing CIA director John Brennan has
leveled a scathing attack against Trump
saying he doesn't understand what the
hell was going on in terms of the threat
posed to the u.s. by Russia and speaking
to Fox News no less Brennan said that
Trump's quote talking and tweeting or
not in the country's best interest but
here's the real kicker Brennan told Fox
News that even though Trump called the
entire thing fake news yes Donald Trump
was briefed about the Russian blackmail
file allegations before they were
reported by CNN of course
Trump's advisors said Oh Trump had no
idea about this Trump calling it all
fake news does anybody realize that at
this point all allegations that the
existence of the dossier not whether the
content is accurate but the existence of
the dossier as well as the fact that
Trump was briefed on it it's real it
happened and we have Trump just saying
it's fake news multiple intelligence
officials say yeah we briefed him about
it yeah their briefing both the
president and the president-elect yeah
with the all the intelligence
communities is not going to denounce
this even though they've known about it
since the summer and now even the Senate
Intelligence Committee is looking into
it and they're led by Republican yeah
we're going to get more into when
exactly the FBI first had that uh knew
about that document we'll talk about
that a little bit later the trumpets
will always twist this defeat via two to
fit their narrative right if pressed
Trump could say well I wasn't briefed on
the day you asked me about whether I was
briefed I was briefed on a different day
Kellyanne Conway all over the news
saying it's all fake news it's not big
news we know that it's true and of
course no one from Trump's team has
retracted any of these statements from
Bennett see more pathological liars I
mean it did no one realize that it
eventually would become
and corroborated that the dossier exists
and Trump was briefed on it again I can
already see the emails from the Trump is
coming in the subject matter the content
of the dossier we don't yet know about
but there is no denying at this point
that the FBI add the dossier that it
makes the allegations that we heard it
makes and that indeed Donald Trump was
briefed about it there is no way that
Trump is going to be able to keep up
with the job of being president right I
mean he can't even keep his lies
straight he's going to be behind on day
one and with BuzzFeed reports I mean
there are plenty of reasons to be
skeptical but when you have Donald Trump
just rejecting this idea and also
rejecting at the same time that the
briefing even happened yeah I think how
can you take that seriously there's no
credibility there usually when
politicians are good at lying they lie
about things that are unfalsifiable
where you can't really even determine
that it was actually false or a lie or a
misstatement Trump doesn't know how to
do that I guess and hey that's that's
cause he's an outsider as the supporters
like to believe we have pathological
lies day after day from Trump and his
advisers send me your thoughts on this
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman